while the u.s faces a record-breaking
surge of new coronavirus cases many of
those infected earlier in the pandemic
they are still healing 64-year-old mark
taragosa contracted the virus earlier
this year
and faced complications that led to not
one not two not three but
four amputations meg oliver has his
remarkable story of perseverance and
recovery
meg good morning to you quite a story
you've got
quite a story indeed good morning gail
it was a choice to live or die
as the family told me and mark has
miraculously turned
one of his greatest lifetime challenges
into a positive
he credits his faith in god for leading
him down this incredible road
to recovery how hard was it to learn to
walk again
i would say it's not easy but
it's a miracle in april karate master
mark taragosa
caught coved i went to work friday
then at night time i had temperature
already
and then i had difficulty breathing i
had
two cardiac arrests that's all how it
started
the healthy 64 year old quickly
developed acute respiratory distress
syndrome a condition that causes fluid
buildup in the lungs
how hard was it for you to see your dad
like that
it was hard i remember vividly when we
took him
to the hospital the first time i was
thinking my head
give him a big hug because i didn't know
if that would be
excuse me last time so at that moment
you were hearing the horror stories
so i gave him a great big hug after
three weeks in the icu
mark's hands and toes were turning
purple he had what's called limb
ischemia blockages in his arteries that
caused significantly reduced blood flow
to his extremities
to save mark's life his family faced the
painful decision
to amputate both hands left foot and
part of his right foot
a lot of times you think end of life
it's cut dry right but this was
different
you know brain wise he was doing great
mark a medical technologist grew up in
the philippines
one of 11 siblings a father and
grandfather who says he lives for his
family
when you woke up and you saw your wife
after your amputations
how did you process how you felt i never
thought of the amputations
at all or linger on the thought of oh i
lost my
limbs what i'm just thinking is how to
go about it
to stand up again but the way i work at
it
is always starting from the mind your
best weapon
is the mind because everything else goes
through the mind
your choices physically spiritually
is always the mind his family say they
were concerned
mark would wake up and be angry that
they took away his independence
we really thought he might be angry for
a while like he might be depressed he's
gonna have to rely on us for a long
while for things that he was able to do
when he was awake
was he depressed was he angry no not
once
how has it changed your relationship
with him we're much more closer i'm
spending more time with him
every waking hours if i'm not at work
i'm with him
[Music]
looking back the eternal optimist can't
help but
brag a little he likes to tell everyone
he was
up and walking within two weeks my
therapist
alex was surprised like
oh my god this is the first time i saw
somebody
without training with walkers or
platforms you just went and walked
yeah after
98 days in the hospital the avid
philadelphia eagles fan celebrated his
triumph
walking independently out of the
hospital his arms
in the air how did it feel when you
walked out of the hospital
oh believe it or not
i am so grateful i'm so happy
i could breathe again you know was it
like when the
the eagles beat the giants more than
that no just kidding
if you fire that will open the hand
eight months after being diagnosed with
covet mark continues his work at
physical therapy
strong muscle signals it's like
relearning it again like a
baby he has to relearn everything from
how to sit up without assistance
to feeding himself i just live for the
day
could not be any better than this you
know i'm really grateful grateful
for another chance at life
they're an amazing family one of the
main reasons mark wanted to share his
story as he puts it
sometimes we don't believe what we don't
see and he wanted people to see the
devastating impact that he suffered as a
healthy person
so hopefully more people will take it
seriously tony
oh wow meg that's just a delightful
piece in the end hard journey but what
what a powerful message what a family
what an attitude
i love that he said your best weapon
yeah i wrote that down that your best
weapon is your mind